Saturn was one of the
most radical innovations
in work organization of
the last several decades,
but it was not alone.
So let's take a look at
a number of companies
that are proof of
concept that you
can compete with what
we call high road
strategies, with good
jobs that provide
good returns to shareholders,
by using what we call
human capital, that is,
essentially workers, skills,
and their social networks
to drive innovation,
good jobs, and high performance
for the organization.
Let's start with one that I
think almost everyone knows,
Southwest Airlines.
This is an airline that
was created in the 1970s,
and it's been an anomaly to
our friends on Wall Street.
Southwest has been one of
the most profitable airlines
in the United States
over the last 30 years.
Yet at the same time, it
breaks a lot of rules.
First of all, it's been roundly
criticized by Wall Street
for not expanding fast enough,
not growing fast enough,
but using its retained
earnings to share them
more equitably with
their employees
than growing the airline.
Secondly, it's highly
unionized airline.
Wall Street thinks
unions are a drag.
Third, it has the
best customer service
of any airline in the country,
and it builds that customer
service by engaging
employees in successful ways.
And it has continued
to be successful
even after the retirement of
its charismatic founder, the CEO
Herb Kelleher.
We're now on the fourth
CEO at Southwest,
and it continues to do well.
And so Southwest does get good
ratings from its employees.
And now, even, it gets good
ratings from Wall Street.
So this is from a
Glassdoor survey
where employees can
voluntarily offer
their assessment of their
companies and their CEO.
And you can see
that Southwest is
ranked number one in the country
in terms of a place to work.
So we can do this.
We can make companies,
design companies that
are successful for employees
by listening to them,
by engaging them, by
engaging in the teamwork
that Southwest
provides, as well as
producing high quality
services and highly profitable
companies.
But Southwest is not alone.
Let's dig a little bit
deeper and understand
what the difference is between
a high road and a low road
company.
Let's do that by first
looking at Walmart,
and then comparing it to
another company called Costco.
As you know, Walmart
is the largest employer
in the United States.
It has over 1.2 million,
quote, "associates."
They like to use
the term associates
to describe their employees.
Walmart has been
successful financially.
Yet Walmart has the tightest
controls on its employees.
It gets its financial
success by having, as you
know, a motto of low
prices all the time.
How does it get
those low prices?
By having very low wage rates,
by controlling employees,
by having high
turnover so employees
don't become more expensive.
It has no unions, and in fact,
it fights unions tooth and nail
to make sure it stays non-union.
So here's a company that
works for shareholders
but is very tough
on its employees.
But then compare that to Costco.
Costco competes with
some of Walmart's stores
that are called Sam Club.
And Costco has a
very different model.
It emphasizes product quality,
it emphasizes customer service,
it pays wages that are
higher than Walmart.
It allows employees
to unionize if that's
what they choose to do.
So some of their stores are
unionized and some are not.
It has a very long
tenure of its employees
because they learn
about the business
and they become more
productive over time.
And so here we have
two alternatives.
We have a high road
employer called Costco.
We have a low road
employer called Walmart.
Both can be reasonably
successful financially,
but only one can be
successful financially
and provide good jobs
and good opportunities
for its employees.
And in fact, this
chart shows that Costco
has outperformed Walmart
on financial grounds
in recent years.
And so there are
two ways to compete.
There's a low road.
There's a high road.
Let's review.
Just how do you get these
high road practices?
How can you build companies
that are successful
for both investors, for
employees, and for customers?
Well, it starts by
selecting employees
both for technical skills
and for teamwork skills
so that they're ready to
work together effectively
with their colleagues.
Secondly, it requires continuous
training and investment
of front line workers
as well middle managers
and supervisors.
It requires us to work together
to build a culture of trust
at the workplace,
to engage employees,
and to get them to want to
cooperate with each other
to get the jobs done.
It requires compensation systems
that align the incentives so
that employees share in the
income and the productivity
that they help to produce by
profit sharing or various kinds
of incentive systems.
It requires, if unionized,
to have labor management
partnerships where labor and
management work together,
and the union leaders are
taken into the confidence
of management representatives
to get the job done together.
And these principles
apply to organizations
not just in the US, but
all around the world.
Recall that we mentioned earlier
companies like Semco in Brazil,
where employees help
design their own jobs
and work in partnership
with management
to improve operations,
and sometimes
to create new businesses.
Or Ikea in Sweden.
Or let's take the
classic example of Toyota
in Japan or in its plants
all around the world.
In fact, Toyota's model of
so-called lean production
is the source of many of
the ideas and practices that
need to be fitted together
in high road firms
to achieve world class
productivity, quality,
and good jobs.
We're going to see
in another video
my colleague Zeynep Ton
talking about a grocery chain
here in the Northeastern
part of the United States
that has been very successful
in building a company that
works for shareholders as well
as customers and employees.
And in fact, the
employees and managers
revolted to save the company
from a change in strategy
in the summer of 2014.
So let's get on with
the task of building
these high road,
good jobs companies,
or, if you're not
in a top management
position at the
moment, demanding
that your employer follow
these principles wherever
you happen to live and work.
That's the challenge
you face, not only
in creating these, but spreading
these to become the norm
across American industry.